what's up guys so as you guys already
know many PC components are very
overpriced right now such as graphics
cards Ram and even SSDs various factors
such as cryptocurrency mining the NAND
flash shortage and even a huge demand
for PC parts due to many new PC gamers
and the releases of ricin and conflict
have contributed to this huge increase
in PC part prices some PC parts have
even doubled in price like some GPUs and
some parts like Ram have gone up
significantly if you guys are interested
in when I think RAM and graphics cards
prices will go down but make sure to
check out my videos on that by clicking
in links in description below normally
it's a no brainer than most cases if not
all cases building a PC was once cheaper
but now times have changed and in many
cases buying a Prevot is actually
cheaper because those pre building
companies already bought those PC parts
and both before the huge increases in
price and so they're able to offer their
pcs at a much more reasonable price than
building one for yourself if you're
interested in the top three builds that
I think eggs are in the market right now
and make sure to click my link in the
video for that as well fortunately some
ranges of PCs are still cheaper to build
but there are still more expensive than
what they used to be as a result what
should you do should you buy or build
well if you're looking at a budget PC
for 500 to 800 dollars within with the
gtx 1050 or 1050 Ti then this issue
doesn't really affect you even here
building a PC is sometimes a bit more
expensive at 10 to 15 dollars more but
other times it's a bit cheaper so it's
very minimal and so it really doesn't
matter if you want to build it yourself
and one customizability then just build
yourself if you don't care and would
prefer the convenience of a pre both and
just buy a prebuilt now if you're
looking for a PC in the eight hundred
twelve hundred dollar range then that is
when it starts to get a bit sketchy ask
for lower and mid-range computers with
the gtx 1063 gigabyte cards this parody
grossed about $50 for pcs from 800 to
1000 dollars
same goes here if you want to custom
build a PC you should just go for it
because $50 isn't too much and you'd
probably enjoy it much
or however if you're on a tight budget
and prefer to get the keyboard and mouse
for free from the PC and a prebuilt is
where you should look ask for mid pcs
with the gtx 1066 in Quebec card is
actually about the exact same price
either way many pre-built in this range
have sold out or their prices have gone
up significantly so for this range you
can still do whatever you want
next entering the premium level with the
1070 graphics card building a PC
yourself is actually insanely much
cheaper currently it is $150 cheaper
however if the reference gtx 1070 card
goes out of stock and this build
actually be $100 more expensive than a
prebuilt so if you are playing to build
a PC with the 1070 you better snatch
that reference graphics card before it's
too late
next onto Hyatt PC your inch with 1080
graphics card unfortunately this is one
custom pcs take a huge hit and are much
more expensive than pre-built it's very
sad because this is a solely due to
practice card alone we all know that the
graphics card is the usually the highest
percentage cost of a gaming PC built but
right now a 1080 could be over half of a
gaming PC build even with the decent
parts this is very unfortunate and
leaves the custom 1080 build at almost
$300 more at this point it is definitely
a much smarter decision to just buy a
prebuilt if you really want to build a
PC at this range still yeah I recommend
that you try to wait and just be patient
because at this point it is quite a
hefty difference you could even buy
another high-end CPU with the my
disparity so it really is a tough
situation
finally the enthusiast market with 1080
eyes has a very similar similar story to
tell you are still looking at about $250
premium if you want to build a PC in
this range by yourself as a result I
recommend that you wait if you insist on
building a PC by yourself
as for AMD the only car that you should
consider is the 560 this card is almost
at MSRP and it's very similar to 1050
so it is definitely some
consider but unfortunately in most cases
pcs in this range are cheaper with free
bills because they are able to buy parts
for cheaper in bulk and builders have to
buy a Windows separately which adds a
huge bulk to the cost in this scenario
building is actually almost $150 more
all other AMD graphics cards including
Vega not even worth considering when
building because they are even up to
double their normal price so I don't
recommend anyone to buy those however
it's a prebuilt range or x57 pcs are
still at a very reasonable price so it
is definitely worth considering if you
were looking at rx 580 then just go for
a GTX 1060 because it is almost
identical and performance and 1060 pcs
are much better priced so in conclusion
currently the only GPU that you should
definitely build with is the 1070 but
that might change in the very imminent
future if you're looking at lower end
build then GPUs on both sides are very
similar in performance and price and
building is almost identical to buy a
prebuilt so do what you please here in
the mid-range in your media is
definitely the more reasonable option
and here building and buying again about
the same so choose what you prefer
finally for high-end builds you should
definitely go with Nvidia and wait if
you want to build overall since most of
you guys are mid-range builders you
aren't too affected but it is
unfortunate that we are at a point where
in many cases people are cheaper so
should you buy a prebuilt well in a
mid-range if we were going to build a PC
to save money that you should just buy a
prebuilt because they are the same price
if not cheaper if you really prefer to
build a PC because you enjoy building
pieces and like the customization
opportunities and for most people this
is still a much better choice if you're
building a lower end PC then building a
PC is still not much more expensive so
you guys should definitely not buy a
prebuilt just for a couple of dollars
however if you're looking into the
high-end market for gaming pcs then I
strongly recommend you go with the
pre-built or wait till prices drop at
least a hundred dollars big surprise
disparity is really quite substantial
right now
so here to take away unless you are
looking into building a high-end PC
I used to recommend that you build a PC
if that's what you want to do even if it
cost a little bit more well guys that's
what I think about building versus
buying in 2018 let me know what you guys
are thinking by posting in the comments
down below I'm curious as to what you
guys think well guys that's all I have
for you guys this time if you like this
video make sure to drop a like and if
you guys loved it make sure to subscribe
and hit that Bell or efficacious to be
notified whenever I post a new video but
that's all I have for you guys this time
until the next video bye
[Music]